dans le trou un moustique de guerrier
bleu est tombé dans le trou du plastique
la fille du bleu se perdue dans le trou
irradier le saddha bleu a fondu sa
voiture explosée les yeux bleus lessive
où est passé ma mère où est passé mon
père je trouve plus mes jouets c'est
tout à brûlé comment je prends de ta vie
c'est génépu de guerrier j'ai besoin
d'un sans ressentir mémé mon amour mon
amour bleu ça
à quoi j'ai joué c'est une épidémie sur
qui j'ai tiré sur qui j'ai pleuré je
besoin d'incendie pour oublier mes morts
je besoin d'incendie pour inventer à
Paul la voiture du plastique du terrier
bleu perdu je n'ai plus un moustique
sous la vitre fondue un jouet de perdu
dans l'éclair et électrique les jouets
bleus fodus les jouets font la nuit
pas trop elle le cadeau pas trouvé le
drapeau je me tiens m'enfermé dans la
chambre à coucher dans le coffre à jouer
le couvert fermé j'adore les Simpsons
mon amour mon amour plus soldat
mon amour mon amour bleu soldat
mon amour mon amour en bleu salle